so Manley's just been to the hospital
she's found out the gender of our second
baby have you know at this and she's not
told anybody
she's not even told me so we've got a
choice we can only mean you can go out
for coffee and you can tell me privately
but we've decided that we're gonna be
outlandish and a mother who's gonna
reveal it to our deal finding
extravaganza group on stage in about
five minutes Don is how about that yeah
so all I don't know yet what the gender
is but I'm gonna find out at the same
time as everybody else and I will be so
furious it is one particular gender so
furious now I'm just playing I care as
long as they as long as it's mine I'm
fine the worst of it is that the worst
of it is that particular gender and it's
not mine no so it is mine of EOB medium
so we'll see
[Applause]
[Music]
I would never - this is the
constellation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wonderboy
putting sign up cuz then if it was again
after do fight surprise
oh all oh Jesus
[Applause]